there's coach Carlisle there MAV said
coach hi coach how are you hi I am here
okay I'm here and I'm pretty sure Billis
does have a jet so really no he's with
that law firm and he's a partner they
gotta have a jet where do you sit on the
team plane I sit in the middle section
there's a section where the coach's
assistant coaches so the players are up
front there's a middle section in in the
back section
you know broadcasting and PR and stuff
like that
so do you care what the players are
doing on the plane I trust them
how are you guys on the Celtics how were
those plane trips well back in those
days we were we were flying commercial
we were going through airports and it
was it was quite different you know I
mean guys like Larry Bird you know were
you know we would go into an airport and
he'd kind of find a corner and you know
kind of face out the window and because
at that time he was the best player in
the world and and he was getting mobbed
you know for autographs and the light I
just can't imagine commercial travel
like will Chamberlain flew commercial I
just I can't imagine what that did to
the careers your body you know just that
the flying time connecting flights
flights delayed cancelled crazy
well it certainly extended Jay builds
his career Congrats on the wind last
night I was curious about the defense
that you had on on Zion it felt like
that porzingis was always going to be
help there but what was the what was the
strategy there
well number one thing is you got to get
back because I am just on the floor very
quickly and if he's in space and they
throw it up I mean he goes up and gets
it if you try to front him he they throw
it over your head and he just gets it
dunks it so we're just trying to stay in
front of him keep a body there bring
help when we could he's very very
difficult to play because of how quickly
he attacks and how dynamically he
attacks but you know it was his first
back-to-back last night and I thought
you know he played extremely well
considering that fact yeah it is
interesting he looked tired last night I
don't know if you got that sense
watching him well you know open their
total team would would feel tired but
you know they lost the game the night
before at home to Minnesota which was a
big game for them and you know they came
in you know obviously very very
motivated last night and you know in
national TV games there's a different
there's a there's a different vibe to
them because they are longer timeouts
are longer there's just a there's just
kind of different air to the game
I think denying probably was a bit tired
I you know I didn't I didn't talk to him
I didn't ask him but I do know that you
know in overtime at the end they threw
the ball and he just you know he he blew
the rim and laid it in quick twice yes
very tired and so I'm gonna Rick
Carlisle the Mavs head coach they got
the Grizzlies coming up tomorrow night I
love how we always have to have a
comparison who is the comp you know and
you've been through this before with
players players who've played with or
you've coached and you know even Porsha
I don't know if there's a comp for
porzingis there might be we might have a
better comprehend we do porzingis I find
him fascinating because how many players
can give you five threes in five blocks
and
the same game well there are many and
you know in today's world of metrics the
guys that can make the high value shots
which are the threes and prevent the
higher value shots which are the layups
are at an all-time premium and so you
know we're fortunate you know cleaver is
a guy that can make threes and it's a
good rim protector but got seven three
you know so there's a there's a bit of a
difference there porzingis is a very
very special player with with with very
special abilities and as you saw last
night
i mean it's not just being able to shoot
and block a shot I mean the guy drives
it he passes it you know he rolls and
finishes he's got real feel for the game
so you know I just you know super
impressed and very happy for him you
know with Player of the Week last week
you know it kind of culminates then
validates all the work he's put in over
two years to get back in and try to get
back to where he wants to be when did
you realize that you were turning the
team over to Lucca on the floor pretty
pretty early the first year it was just
a it was just a matter of when the
structure of the team could be adjusted
to do that
you know I it was clear to me the first
time I saw him play a pickup game in our
place in September 2018 that he was
legitimately a point guard even though
he's six seven and a half and big strong
and all that and and you know we the New
York trade helped facilitate that and
then you know there were a couple moves
last summer that that helped structure
the team so that you know we had some
depth at point guard and some shooting
around him and along with some toughness
and length how do you add
and you were around birds so you know
great players always add something every
year but let's just say offensively what
would you want Luka to work on at the
ripe old age of 21 for next year you
know for me he just needs to keep
refining his game his game is very very
special you know what he can do with the
ball with his ball skills and being able
to step back and accelerate and
decelerate and step back keep his
dribble and then go by somebody you know
it's just it's just freaky you know and
so you know the things that that go
along with that finishing you know the
the threes all those kinds of things
he's going to continue to refine his
ability to make the the proper reads etc
and and you know I think all great young
players as they go from their first a
second to third to fourth year realize
that that continuing to work on their
body and and just every year you know
doing things to you know help help your
durability help your ability to stay on
the floor you know you're gonna have
games like last night where you
unexpectedly go to overtime and you're
also you played 45 minutes 40 minutes
instead of you know 35 and you've got to
be able to absorb that who would be your
MVP right now in the league hmm wow I
don't know I haven't watch I haven't
studied the stats I know the the
conversation really is is he honest in
the Brawn right yeah yeah it's very very
close and Milwaukee's been so dominant
and they're going to have I haven't
looked at the standings today but you
know they're going to have the best
record most likely and
yeah they'll have 70 winners maybe yeah
I mean I don't know I lose and I you you
look at the league this year and what's
going on with those two guys I mean they
both deserve it I mean I I to me you
just get two trophies and get them
together and you have a picture you know
I mean they're just and you know the
west and the East are different and so
you know in so many ways what LeBron is
doing is even that much more impressive
and luckily the same things gonna come
up with morant and in Williamson and I
mean hey get two trophies out man how
about they play one-on-one coach no no
no there could be an injury I mean I
wouldn't want to do that but I but I I
just think I think these guys are both
you know transcended talents I mean
we're so lucky I mean you know dodge
comes in the league last year you got
you got Moran Williamson this year and
there's a lot of other great young
players you know it's just a really
really exciting time in the NBA and
they're all like the if I got a team I
wanted to have my my team in there under
23 years of age and I'll give you the
rest of the like you can have an
under-23 and put together an
unbelievable team and that would be
unheard of a decade ago two decades ago
yeah you're right and you know but these
things are cyclical you know we we don't
we don't get this wave of generational
talent you know every year every other
year every you know two years in a row
like this very often and so it's just
it's been a special period or you know
the injection of of talent and it sound
like talent I mean let's face it it's
you're talking about major charisma I
mean these guys I mean you know Luka Don
Cheech and Zion and Moran I mean I mean
these guys are you know they're not just
great basketball players just like movie
stars you know with with it with the the
analogy they have on the floor and how
they how they command the attention on
social media and those kinds of things
is really it's really quite an amazing
time 35 years ago this week you know
what happened there five years ago this
week gosh it's March of 20 it was 85 I
don't know
go ahead bird scored 60 against the
Hawks in New Orleans hey you should see
what we were doing late the night before
if you if you wouldn't seen our group
that that night in New Orleans you
wouldn't have thought that 60 points out
of anybody was going to be possible how
bad did it get on Bourbon Street with
you guys I was bad it's just you know
this is one of the legendary things
about you know Larry Bird I mean he just
and I remember that game so well
University of New Orleans
you know the Atlanta bench every time
you throw in another howitzer haymaker
shot you know there was one there was a
step-back three where he made the shot
then they disallow the basket and all
those guys you know we're falling
sideways and it almost a couple of were
falling on the floor you know it was
just I mean it was it was some melon and
the other thing about it was that in the
previous eight to ten days I don't
remember the exact time McHale set the
record right yeah McHale had set the
record at 56 I think against Detroit and
in that game bird was the guy that went
out of his way to keep feeding Kevin you
know over and over and over again I
remember after that game I think Kevin
said hey look this is this is fine this
is you know they say Larry's gonna learn
embraces just a matter of win is so
contrary yeah yeah so you know um and
ten days later in you know in New
Orleans of all places
you know Larry just I mean it was do you
think you did it on purpose Rick that
McHale got the record and then bird saw
an opportunity where you know what might
as well do it tonight
I don't know i'd be really speculating
there i mean you know it's really
interesting i you know we played a game
my my rookie year i think was in utah
something like that and you know we got
way ahead it was you know it was the
height of the Salieri's greatness and
you know the the team was was
spectacular and utah was was an
up-and-coming team they had some
talented guy that said earlier we got up
Larian shot they put us up you know 28
or something with a minute to go in the
third quarter so KC Jones calls my name
to go in the game and I and I go in and
I go in for Larry and I don't remember
his exact stats I just know that he had
over 30 points you know 12 or 14
rebounds 10 or 11 assists and nine
steals okay so he was one steal away
from a quadruple double and I remember
being in the locker room after the game
and one of the one of the writers asked
and they learned it you know did you did
you have any interest in going back in
there and getting that you know steal to
get a quadruple double and and and this
is this relates to your question about
60 points and this is one reason you
know I just never I just never felt it
that stats were were the the thing for
him he said you know when you're a
younger player you know and you're and
you're trying to make your way in the
league this is a very honest answer
because you know sometimes things like
that are you know important to you
because but once you get your contract
and then you realize that you know the
real respect comes from you know how
many championships you get
you know stuff like that this doesn't
matter to me anymore you know so I
thought it was you know an amazing
answer and very very matter-of-fact very
very authentic you know well he could
average a triple-double I you know I
mean he I agree with you I don't think
it was about stats because it wasn't a
thing back that I know Oscar did it but
you know the russell westbrook made it
popular but I think Bernie could have
averaged a triple-double for a few of
those seasons can you do the the quick
story you know about when your coach I
think it was Casey Jones forgot your
name and the huddle can you do that
story real quick because bird played a
role in that
yeah no it was we were in March of my
first year and we were playing a game in
Hartford Connecticut back in those days
we played three regular season games
there and so Casey walks down on the
bench I hadn't played in a couple of
weeks and he he looks at me and he goes
he kind of gives me a head nod he goes
you got Danny says Danny Ainge so so I
you know nudge my way into the huddle
and Casey starts you know drawing up a
play and you know he goes Larry your
year and he puts it on and Robert your
year it's Robert Parish if it's an hour
Kevin you're here he puts okay Dennis
you know you got the ball he's got a
puts a D in a circle and a squiggle with
a guy Streelman ball and he goes and he
goes you right here he puts it he just
puts us like a scribble mark if you like
to sit you know and so anything any
calls it may the name of the place so we
stand up on the huddle and in there he
goes Casey I want you to six months
missus Casey and we laugh you know and
it was and I remember we're playing
against Chicago and you know it was it's
a serious business for me you know I'm
trying to stay in the league and stuff
like that but but the the levity of the
situation actually helped you
a little bit loosen up I actually went
in there I think I end up parking it and
and actually did okay you know what it
was a funny moment that's great it's
always great to talk with you Rick we
appreciate your time and good luck
against the Grizzlies and thanks for
joining us I know I'm gonna have to
check with him that's a Rick Carlisle a
head coach of the Dallas Mavericks